boris johnson in downing street signing
the post-brexit
trade deal flanked by his as you would
see it's successful
negotiators the treaty flown across
the channel by the raf even as this
document's been signed
the house of lords uh debating uh the
bill
it's a rushed process five hours of
commons debate
earlier today resulting ultimately in a
vote that was heavily
in the government's favor as expected
some 500 in excess of 500
votes for the government to 73
um not voting with the government let's
listen to what the prime minister had to
say
good well thank you very much everybody
i want everybody to understand that uh
the the treaty that i i've just signed
is
is not the end it is it is a new
beginning
and i think the beginning of what will
be a wonderful relationship between
the uk and our friends and partners in
the european union i would like to
welcome
uh with us today in number 10. uh here
it is
folks this isn't it uh and uh i know the
question you'll all be asking yourselves
is
is have i read it the answer is yes
and it's an excellent deal for this
country but also
for our friends and partners thank you
all very much i want to pay particular
tribute
uh to those who led the negotiations
uh i i mean of course uh commissioner uh
vandalia michelle barnier on our
uh on the eu side uh stephanie so many
others
uh and of course on on the uk side i
want to pay
a massive tribute to uh
on my right so tim on my left
uh oliver uh sonic uh
jono uh matthew lindsey
and many many others who've done an
absolutely horrid job
in record time thank you all very much
thank you
thank you